[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we start this week with three big
questions
how many brackets are too many brackets
what school does cinderella go to
and who will be eating steak at prime 47
in indianapolis after the nets are cut
down welcome to the squad ride a special
tournament edition live in the bleacher
report app my name is kaby richards
part cheat code part glitch in the
matrix is our betting expert kelly
stewart
and the man responsible for vibes and
locks
is greg ivory look some people bet via
the mascot
some people bet on the seeds some people
bet using their gut feelings
and other people use actual information
like the young lady in the middle but we
all are betting
that we know who's gonna win the big
dance
so kelly stewart gonna start with you
before we get to the big dance
which teams are in your final four let's
take a look at the graphic before you
answer the question
these are the latest odds we have here
gonzaga at the top the number one
overall seed in the tournament
baylor illinois michigan houston
it goes down the list kelly kells do us
a favor
who are you locking in as the final four
teams in the tournament
look this isn't any fun cabbie i'm at
the gym this morning i'm on the
treadmill and i look up on the tv
we've got these guys talking final four
and every single one has got three
if not four one seeds and here i am
giving out a one seed to start off and
i'm just like i
it pains me you guys know i love these
underdogs and here i am
giving out the zags they're the betting
favorite for a reason
look i want to bet against them but
they've already beaten iowa they've
already beaten ku they've already beaten
virginia so here we are
i gotta take the zags to win the west
zags win in the west kelly uh
gonzaga they always make it far they
always make it far but they always come
up short i like that pick kelly i like
it
it would be it's a greg's point it would
be the first team in 45 years
to go undefeated through the entire
season and the tournament
and win the uh to win the national
championship so
tough task but they're the best team in
the league who else you got kells in
your final four
so in the south region this is the one
i'm not that confident in
i could make it a case for probably four
or five teams
but i like the ohio state buckeyes i
think they really worked out their kinks
but this isn't me betting on ohio state
this is me betting against the one seed
that is baylor speaking of kinks this
team had a
lot of problems in the big 12 tourney
they struggled
with teams like my wildcats as 20-point
favorites you cannot
expect this team to start caring all of
a sudden
in a big 12 tournament where they
basically ran the table i think it
carries over
into the big tournament so i like ohio
state here
but i can make a case for a few other
teams okay so gonzaga
ohio state so you have a one seat and a
two seat who else you got
well i got another one seed oh cows we
i thought you hated one scene it drives
me nuts i want to have like
uh a sister jean like 11 seed loyal in
chicago being there but i just
i i'm looking in this year and and given
the current landscape
it's kind of hard it feels like 2018
where there is going to be that sister
gene loyola chicago
but unfortunately villanova won as the
one seed
whatever anyway i like brad underwood a
lot that's kind of uh
my little piece i really enjoyed him at
kansas state i really liked him at
oklahoma state i think he's done a
really
great job with this illinois team and i
think illinois
cruises wins the midwest ah let's see
who do i have notes i have oklahoma
state
and west virginia i think they could
cause a little bit of issues there
but more than likely oh illinois is
going to just not cover those games
but probably cruise right into the final
four kelly i think it sounds like you're
turning into one of those people you
were uh
you were hating at the gym looking on
the treadmill you have a one seed a two
seed and another one seed
who do you have is your your fourth in
the final four another
another two seed kathy i told you i
already i asked the producer can we just
ask this segment
let me just give out like nine underdogs
i think they have the chance to win
round one and boom there's the show
i like alabama now this alabama team
showed me a lot in the sec championship
game but why do i think that they're
going to be in the final four
because they have to beat the one seed
that is
michigan if the you bet you put these
two up against each other michigan will
be about a one and a half two point
favorite
and i'm gonna tell you this right now
what's the old adage take the better
defense plus the points
i like the crimson tide so after you've
gone through your spreadsheets kel's
you've run your simulations
uh you've tapped in with neil in the
matrix who do you like to win it all
before you enter let's take a look at
the latest odds here
to win the entire tournament
vern is in the comments vernon oh salute
talking talking some smack to you isn't
he supposed to be robbing the rich and
giving to the poor
he says you're eating that chalk kelly
and he said yeah minus
2 30. vern i will give you a hoodie but
uh
i don't want you to get in trouble at
your new job so gonzaga is right at the
top there
plus 205 the the as you said kel's the
overall
betting favorite who are you locking in
to win the 2021
national championship cabbie there is a
bet here in vegas that it's not
gonzaga and not baylor you could bet the
fields i actually want to take that bet
i haven't taken it yet and i may
because i don't like this pick but i
just told you exactly the scenario i see
planning out
when they put this together the entire
west
they just handed gonzaga the final four
on a silver platter and said here you go
here's some teams you guys have already
beaten
it's it's your choice to beat to win it
all or not it reminds me of 2018
villanova
i i hate this but i'm going to take the
zags i think that they have a nice
easy path to get there i hope somebody
beats them i hope i lose this bet this
is the first time i'm ever gonna say on
the show
i hope i lose this one i hope this is
like a fun
five seed versus like a three seed and
we get an awesome national championship
game instead
that would be a lot of fun okay so we
kel's we hope that you enjoyed this part
of the show a little bit more
we're building a four-legged final four
parlay
so um and this is gonna be the one to
hit so greg
we are gonna each one of us are gonna
pick a leg greg's gonna pick
you're gonna pick i'm gonna pick and we
have a special guest picking
um but so we need g money we need to
assemble
the winners only army because as a squad
we gotta tap in everybody
everybody i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me who is ruining
our parlay who in the squad has the
worst
pick whoever you vote we're going to
kick them out we're just going to simply
kick them out of the parlay and replace
them with one of your picks
i'm starting this off i'm starting it
off i'm
rocking with illinois here uh
they just won the championship
conference championship looked
great they got the masked mamba cabbie
like you
as you like to call them uh absolutely
they look poised they look
poised they look they look good and i'm
i'll put my money on them
any day the way they've been looking
recently uh but cabbie
who are you riding with okay so you
picked uh
a conference champion i'm taking a
conference champion from the sec
kelly mentioned them earlier the alabama
crimson tide i love javon quinn early
the point guard
he's got a lot of gusto um you know
they've won
nine of their last ten this is a team
with a lot of confidence
six in a row and they're rolling and
here's how alabama kills you
eighty percent of their points come from
inside the paint
or beyond the three-point line so you
pick your poison 40
from beyond 41 from in the paint alabama
is rolling
they're the number two seed michigan's a
little bit shaky
although salute to juwan howard i like
alabama
coming out of the east bracket kel's you
guys already got two of my picks i'm
gonna go with the third one that's not a
one seed i'm gonna take the ohio state
buckeyes look
like i said this is more of a play
against the baylor bears i'm not sold on
this team and i think that ohio state
yes
they looked terrible the last few games
before
their big ten conference championship
and you know what they flipped the
switch
they proved to me that this team can
compete and i think they're going to
compete really well in the tournament i
do think that they will make it to the
final four
we got to go to the bullpen and grab the
biggest of the loch ness
monsters mikey locks sir who do you have
for us complete our final four parlay
keepers favorites you gotta grind i've
been up all night
grinding doing my research who do we
like where do we like them what yacht
are we taking after we hit our final
four part light
breaking down the west region there's a
lot of good teams here the zags
you see santa barbara sleepy ohio sc
kansas iowa
i like oregon as a seven seat i know
they're a long shot to come out i like
them to make the final four
take a motion out of it don't bet with
your heart bet with your brain
i have no affiliation to the ducks um i
just think they're a solid ball club so
i think oregon has the seven seat coming
out of the west region
to the final four booked up
yo greg did he actually say take your
heart
out of it or to take the emotion out of
it isn't mikey lux's biggest emotional
better of anybody that we know
oregon one of the biggest and he's
actually
an organ alumni for those people that do
not know but my guy
mikey looked like it was signing day he
looked like he was about to sign an
organ or something
coming up coming out the shirt shouts
out to mikey he's on the screen
and he's in the comments he can do two
things at once man you really can
shout out to that guy and also anger
kelly so our final four parlay okay so
we have
uh we have oregon the ohio state
alabama and illinois this is only four
percent of the squad the other 90
of the squad are you guys in our
audience and in the comments
so unfortunately one of us four are
getting kicked out of this parlay
um so g money we need a winner only
please so tap in with your army and let
us know
which one of the four of us getting
kicked out of this farley winners
only and winners only please cabby is
what we need
let me introduce some people that do not
know what this is this is called
the handy dandy ipad this is how you get
your hoodies i'm in the comments and i
see
raider 909 ohio state ain't making it to
the sweep
wow wow a lot of salt there a lot of
salt but i'm going to spice it up
because
because raider you are walking away with
the hoodie uh
chipotle poppy 89 that bama pics
needs to go it is more rated
what overrated they won 9 of 10 chipotle
by the way love the handle might get one
after the show
uh all right here we go strip stripling
warrior says
uh stripling warrior says the highest
ranked number two
scene has never made it to the finals
well at least not in the last 10 years
come on grego claus
it it's mean i i don't even
yeah i'm so sorry it is a lot
oh oh i'm sorry i'm sorry he said it
mean a lot if i can get a hoodie
shout out to you stripling warrior
you're walking away wait
wasn't he just wasn't he just crapping
on your illinois pick with all that with
that information about the
highest number two seed oh no illinois
illinois is a one seed so he wasn't
those vibes wasn't directly uri
those vibes was not directed to me uh
i got not zion saying mikey is wrong i
got t d
nil under slash br says mikey wtf
it's an independent what do you expect
this is how you have to do it you got to
set the bar low when it comes to mikey
you set the bar low
you're never surprised you're never
disappointed
nico spin nico spin spina eight says
gonzaga all the way
and uh chase seven says why not gonzaga
the first undefeated champion
i think i'm gonna uh i don't think i'm
gonna make the call here cabbie i think
birds
didn't larry burns india hoosiers have
something to say about the undefeated
champion i'm pretty sure
well he went indiana state indiana
hoosiers was isaiah thomas indiana state
was larry bird but right in the same era
right so wait who's who's getting kicked
out cabbie kelly hold on just a second
mikey the producer's just whispered in
my ear mike he's getting kicked out
and he's getting replaced with chase
because mikey bet it with his heart
he better with the course doesn't he
always he's an alumni from oregon
they're plush 2500 for a reason um
mikey we don't need that we don't need
those vibes today i'm sorry brother we
will have the three by two vibes
tomorrow
but today we do not need the organ vibe
so we're rocking with chase and gonzaga
to uh finish up this four leg parlay
this is wait so we just duplicated
kelly's
final four parley ticket is basically
what we did
great now i feel super confident as if i
already didn't hate my final four enough
i love it people between me all day and
i'm like
you guys don't want my final four it's
terrible i gotta have some water you're
real brackets
that's the only way you can win you
gotta you gotta pick some upsets
don't worry i'll make sure i get i'll
get you guys all the upsets this week
okay so uh speaking of our audience
desperate
not our audience cocky secretive
degenerates uh we all know people in our
personal lives either our friends
or our co-workers who are the worst
bettors ever we just dropped a a
bracket on social with the worst bettors
ever tournament this is this is special
because we all know
these types of people and we need you we
need your help
to choose the biggest loser at all
personally number 13 and i love that
it's number 13
the jinx is an amazing uh
type of better um g-money i'm looking at
this list and kelly stewart is about
five of these bettors
i'm just scanning this list right at the
bottom the unit shamer
greg you mentioned that vern and mikey
locks are in the comments kelly used to
light up both vern
and mikey locks about their units for
sure and callous is also
the i told you so when you lose better
she's hit
she hits you with that every week on our
other show
but she's absolutely those too and
g-money before i
let you get like i let you run with it
you are number six bro that lies about
his losses because
what you're so secretive g-money that
like and we know you love your army
you like to get these picks you know you
cherry pick them from your but we don't
know how much you're losing you never
reveal how much
do you even actually bet bro do you even
actually
be asking me do i actually bet
the guy
you got a new jaguar that you posted on
instagram like four months ago but we
haven't seen it since
have you lost that jaguar in one of your
in your freaking super bowl picks or
a you know nba recently or whatever hey
the jaguars still out in front kevin
i bring i bring the jag out time to time
but uh
speaking about betting i mean i've
earned my strike people know that i'll
put it down but cabbie you my friend
when you first came here you you did not
bet
can we pull the graphic back up because
i'm going to run through this really
quick i'm starting off with cabbie
he's 13. he said he likes the jinx for a
reason because that's
exactly what he is you don't want him
around
him around how am i the jinx how am i
the jigs
you don't even bet you don't even know i
can confirm timeouts i'm not great
i can confirm because this person
to the i don't know left of me right of
me which way is this camera going wrong
way
texas heat eight kells i'm not in nevada
right now can i send you a venmo real
quick
and i'm like sure gabby and i
i'm not gonna lie everybody's got one of
those friends so i can confirm he does
that
but greg we all know you're number eight
you love those
l bombs and just hold on so cringe
worthy hold on hold on i'm not
done can we pull that graph you do say
lots
you got the comments you got the
comments they're all over me and usually
they're
on my side people in the comments i
promise you i make bets ask kelly but
i'm back on caddy we've never seen
any of your tickets greg he's number
third
abby oh my god kelly tell him talk to
him you know listen wait
great greg definitely that's i sat there
in the sports book with greg almost
every day for a year
greg definitely bets but greg is number
seven he is number he is greg public
it's not joe public anymore now he is
greg public that's right
you are definitely great drop greg
public in the
in the comments and uh i'll make sure
absolutely got some hoodies
we are kelly and i will give you away
hoodies if you drop greg public in the
comments
for sure all right let me finish this
off cabbie you're number 16 you're a
numbers nerd my guy cabbie will go away
look into his book and come back with
all type of numbers
and reasons why you should be betting
when he doesn't even
bet i definitely bet my dude
i definitely bet no i just locked in
alabama plus 2000 today my g
today alabama plus 2
000. hey i'm learning from i'm learning
from the goat in the middle of the
screen
okay so greg tell us tell us who's
getting roasted in the comments
we're all getting roasted but i'm done
i'm not no yeah we're all getting
roasted but i'm not done
pull that graphic back up because i
gotta talk about kelly i have to talk
about her
i have to please pull it up there it is
she's everyone on this list she's rages
after every loss she refuses to use the
lock word so one
nine uh definitely never
win number one 12 she brags about when
we're losing and she's winning
she's a number four uh she may be a
number six she might lie about her
losses but i don't know
she freaks out over every play i can't
lie
she definitely freaks out over every
play uh number 10 she faced the public
and number two
she fades the group that is terrible
yeah i literally just went down the list
and named everyone for kelly
uh man
man man okay so okay after we just
absolutely flame through each other
that's i don't know if that's a word
but who who's getting who's getting
crushed in the comments right now cabbie
we're we're all getting crushed
i see i see chipotle poppies back into
the comments saying i'm over here
scout cookies at best so you get girl
scout cookies at
best i don't know about these i have no
idea slim reaper 22 says he loves this
uh katie's burner got greg you know the
greater sec
the greater sign he says greg's greater
signs
cabbie sorry cabbie i love you though i
i i promise i love you
uh enderman says greg's going off i'm
not even going off right now i'm not
going off
uh here we go joe white sox greg's
public my guy
i'm definitely a three uh shout out to
you white sox cabbie i got one more
uh not zion says greg is for sure right
he bets obviously i bet brother
everybody i just said you're walking
away with a hoodie everybody i just said
you would walk away
greg public those guys get hoodies give
them some fun yes
yes okay let's get back to bedding kels
uh we need to find out
who your best bet is in the first round
because it's
friday and saturday we know that you're
you have your notes and you're in your
spreadsheets and you have your
14 monitors in front of you which we
can't see but we know that they're there
who do you love for the opening weekend
who's your best bet
so we're gonna go to saturday we're
gonna take a team that not very many
people
talked about up until the other day st
bonaventure plus
one and a half i think it may get up so
just keep an eye on it uh because i
think a lot of people are gonna come in
uh greg public wise
and that lsu minus one and a half so we
may see a two so you don't need to rush
and bet this
but this is my thought process here
besides the fact that the wrong team is
favored why is the wrong team favored
because no one knows who saint
bonaventure is can either one of you
guys name a player on this team
guess what i couldn't either because i
don't follow small conferences like this
this is not a sexy pick wait wait wait
wait kelly are you betting on this team
against
lsu yes so like i said no disrespect to
lsu but they really
outperformed the market last week and
the wrong team is favored here
telling me right now saint bonnie's gets
the w
okay we know that but well done with the
underdog we know that you have an
affinity
for underdogs so can you give us your
underdog of the day
in the opening round right saturday i i
really wanted to go with georgetown and
then i kind of thought man this
georgetown team is getting a little too
trendy for me
i had a couple other dogs on my list and
boom uc santa barbara popped up and i
said
georgetown man georgetown was getting
all this love from the big east
tournament and who did they
beat the absolute bricks off of that's
right
creighton took a bath in that game i
think that this
uh ucsb team can capitalize
exactly what georgetown did that's off
turnovers and off getting boards
this team will excel i like them and
don't forget to sprinkle just a little
bit
on that money line speaking of
sprinkling right here in las vegas are
where dreams are made and some people
hit it
huge when the oregon state beavers won
the pac-12 tournament
championship game first time in school's
history
and they took down enroute to winning
they took down ucla
oregon and colorado and these dudes
right here
made bank take a look at this video
gambling gods please bring us a couple
of these
this in the next four three weeks 150
bucks
to win 150 bands on oregon state beavers
what a pull this is this is the dream
150 000
off two tickets salute to those two
dudes
uh just like in vegas uh we gotta roll
with the hot hand but um
uh and and listen we have a we have a 12
seed versus a five so it's the prime
time
prime matchup for that underdog upset uh
g money tap in with your army what do we
got are the homies in the comments
cabbie let me talk to them get in the
comments tell us if you're riding with
oregon state
tell us your favorite sleeper school to
bet on in the tournament
kelly i know you've been i think man i
don't even know if you've been doing
your research to be honest
but uh who do you why do you love this
oregon state
bet first of all what do you think i do
while you guys are arguing about
miscellaneous things i actually get some
work done when i'm not on camera because
i like some multi tasks look this oregon
state squad absolutely killed it i had
them
plus nine plus nine and plus nine and a
half and number one should i bet the
money line never once did i think that
they could actually win the whole thing
and that pains me but i do think this
oregon state team is scrappy
cabbie mentioned uh that 12-5 seat
there's
every single year there is an upset
brewing i think oregon state has a good
shot to be the one to do it this year
got to love a confident team and i want
to see worth aletiche just dunk over
everybody
uh the oregon state people like listen
we're in las vegas you know what they
say you gotta roll with the hot hands so
we're gonna roll with the hot hand
in their three three game win streak
they've been shooting
45 from three-point range that's like
the brooklyn nets like
these guys are cooking right now so
let's ride the oregon state beavers for
as far as
look at one word of caution they beat
tennessee the five seed
they might face uh oklahoma state in
their next matchup
and cade cunningham was probably going
to be the number one overall seed in the
nba draft in 2021
he's there he might be there waiting so
it's going to be an uphill climb
but love this team as the 12 seed no
12 seed has ever won the tournament but
why not now
why not this year 2021 let's call oregon
state beavers let's get it
let's get rich gee money cabbie
i'ma keep this short you guys you guys
you know you guys talk numbers talk
value whatever
talk players i'm just keep this real
short they're in one of the best
conferences
ever it's on the west the best side the
west side
the pac-12 and that's why i'm rocking
with oregon state
simple it's very simple it is very
simple all right here we go but listen
uh uh tap in with our social channels
because we're gonna have an unbelievable
unbelievable ride uh g money
anything left from before we we say
goodbye yeah let me get in these
comments because they're they're all
over i got
thomas he says rutgers tom skis rocking
with rutgers
did they even make the talk i think they
did i got it
vern said uh kansas sleeper school is
killed oh weird version
percy said he's going to win it all
bursts burns sleeper school he says
kansas i got nico nico's rocking with
georgetown rocking with georgetown uh
let me uh let me let me get some more
hoodies out cabbie
uh i got tom skee i think i already said
rutgers shout out to you tom skee
george taylor is back in nico uh
enderman enderman rutgers rutgers and
rutgers is in the comments a lot
gazi 707 says uh kelly you might be
tripping a little bit shout out to you
guys uh
c mcdaniel 14 rocking with oregon state
he's rocking with
us let's go uh
cabbie i got one more in here okay one
more more emmy uh
schwoozie schwoozie says the hoyas
rocking with the hoyas everybody i said
you're walking away with a hoodie by
by the way i just wanted to hey thank
you thank you to everybody for tapping
in with the squad your favorite squad
uh the br's worst bettors
ever bracket is live tomorrow we posted
it on instagram
and twitter get in the comments and uh
and light up your friend or your
coworker who's the worst better ever
and make sure to send us your reactions
from the tournament
because we need to let's all celebrate
let's all get rich and let's all
have a great tournament alongside kelly
stewart and gregory my name is cabby
richards thanks for joining us
good luck with your wagers and peace
[Music]
you